what's up everybody
so earlier today there was a leaked
description of the first avengers 4
trailer going around online
it sounds really really awesome and it
makes a lot of sense for the first
trailer and a lot of people who have
already read it or heard about it have
been freaking out as well
saying that it is in fact truly awesome
so i did a video about it earlier today
just going over the description in this
video i'm going to
break it down and talk about what each
scene means
there is no real way to know how
legitimate this is but if it
is true there are some huge spoilers so
you have been warned there were some
leaks that came out before
infinity ward that ended up being true
so again
spoiler alert i'm still giving away
copies of avengers infinity war on
blu-ray and ant-man
and the wasp some special edition
posters and memorabilia all you have to
do to enter the giveaway is be a
subscriber
like the video and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so again
final warning for spoilers and i'm just
gonna read this as it stated
if you caught the last video i did on
this and heard the description
already you can jump to 5 minutes and 20
seconds to go straight to the breakdown
the trailer starts off showing the
damaged infinity gauntlet in a field on
the farm planet
as the camera focuses in on the gauntlet
we hear tony's voice
we were destined to lose epic music
score starts
the quinjet is shown landing in a
wakandan wasteland as we hear steve
rogers say
we have come so far tony and nebula step
off the jet as the remaining avengers
approach steve has a look of relief and
says
tony tony seemingly defeated shakes his
head and gives a friendly smirk back to
cap
marvel studios logo appears we get a
glimpse of the battle of new york from
2012
avengers loki is shown looking shocked
and baffled as he is on top of the stark
tower
there's a flash of a blue light as the
camera pants back
cuts to black next we see the wakandan
throne with imbaku at the helm
he is surrounded by his new kingsguard
shuri and banner are seen working on a
new project in the lab
black widow in full gear is in hawkeye's
family home from age of ultron
basically everything is thrown all over
the place and broken
nat is studying some type of map with
multiple photos and locations on it
a quick shot of thanos is shown with a
long sword
walking down an alleyway in new york
city the next shot is a dark hooded
figure with glowing eyes
aiming a bow and arrow before shooting
towards the camera
it then shows one to two visuals of the
quantum realm
scott lang with no suit on is shown
running through a park dodging
explosions
shot of space thor and valkyrie are
aboard a cree
ship thor says if the stories are true
you're our universe's last hope
if such a thing even exists anymore the
next shot is an
older determined tony stark walking
through the new shield headquarters
which is the avengers facility in
upstate new york
he's in full shield attire and carrying
an orange
briefcase banner wearing spandex is seen
running from something looking terrified
the next shot is ant-man appearing out
of a flash of light and landing in a
desolate place
we see it from his point of view from
inside his helmet
he looks left to right and to his left
again and says what in the
camera focuses on vormir and its stars
next a shot of rocket and nebula
modifying some new weapons in the lab
rocket says when can we try this bad boy
out they both
smile at each other and fist bump we get
our first glimpse of iron man and his
red and gold nanotech armor
hulk falls from the sky and lands in
front of him thanos in full armor
smiles hulk smiles back the next shot is
in japan
war machine nat and steve and their full
avengers gear are surrounded by the
yakuza
hawkeye or ronin walks through everybody
from behind them and approaches the
avengers
there's an intense exchange of looks
between clint and natasha
the next shot is at the sanctum wang is
communicating with dr
strange's soul via portal it cuts to
black
gray-haired tony stark and ant-man are
in a post-apocalyptic new york city
the screen flashes back and forth
multiple times through multiple scenes
we see
captain marvel floating with her fists
on fire and her eyes lit up
thanos in the soul stone with young
gamora screaming at him
loki and thor are fighting off chitauri
together and tony handing steve a brand
new shield in the wakandan throne room
cuts back to tony and scott tony opens
the orange briefcase as scott hands him
an illuminated bracelet
tony asks how is this even possible
iron man and ant-man are shown traveling
through the quantum realm
tony and scott are back in the battle of
new york from 2012.
the final shot before the title reveal
is an infinity stone disappearing from
thanos's damaged gauntlet
he abruptly gets up and puts on his
armor his face goes from extremely
infuriated to a menacing smile
title reveal avengers annihilation
then the stinger the hulk is training at
the new shield facility with black widow
and steve
steve notices that hulk has been
training non-stop as of late so he asks
why
hulk responds in banner's normal voice
with
my rematch is coming real soon i can
feel it
okay so we have a ton of stuff to break
down from this trailer description
so let's just start from the beginning
okay so the trailer starts off showing
the damaged infinity gauntlet in a field
on the farm planet
this makes perfect sense because this is
where infinity war
ended it ended with thanos on a distant
planet
on a farmland in a little hut watching
the sunrise
just like he told dr strange he would do
after he completed the snap
and of course the infinity gauntlet is
damaged because thanos did the snap
and the russo brothers said it
themselves that the gauntlet is in fact
permanently damaged
so we hear tony say we were destined to
lose and the quinjet
lands in wakanda and steve rogers says
we have come
so far so this is clearly sort of a node
and a tribute
to the last 10 years of the marvel
cinematic universe of the avengers being
together
the trailer is going to have some of
that aspect in it referencing to the
past 10 years because
this movie is going to be what wraps up
the previous 10 years and starts a new
future
so tony and nebula get off the jet and
regroup with the remaining avengers
tony and nebula were part of the heroes
who were fighting thanos on titan
and after the snap they were the only
two that survived
the rest of the heroes were in wakanda
fighting thanos's army and what was left
of the children of thanos
so this scene is going to be all of the
remaining heroes regrouping it's also
going to be the first
time in a really long time that tony
stark and steve rogers will be seeing
each other
they haven't spoken since the events of
civil war and they never crossed paths
in infinity war so it's been a
really long time but seeing as how half
of the universe just got wiped away from
existence they need to regroup
so steve says tony and tony is seemingly
defeated
shakes his head and gives a friendly
smirk back to captain tony of course
feels defeated after the events of
infinity war because this is something
tony has been planning
for since 2012 since the events of the
battle of new york
so he had been preparing for years for
this but at the end of the day it wasn't
enough
thanos won so tony is defeated on a few
different levels
so the next part goes back to the battle
of new york from
2012 avengers and it shows loki on top
of the stark tower
looking shocked and baffled and there's
a flash of a blue light as the camera
pans back
and then it cuts to black so this is
them introducing time travel
this is most likely why loki is baffled
and confused he probably
just saw iron man who he is currently
fighting
come out of some blue portal and look
like the future version of himself
or thor's the one that goes back in time
so he sees his brother with short hair
and a mechanical eye
and not to mention stormbreaker in the
current time loki would be fighting thor
with
very long hair and mjolnir so seeing his
brother magically appear from a portal
looking completely different would
probably make him look pretty baffled
the next scene with wakanda and its
throne room with ombaku at the helm
makes a lot of sense because t'challa is
gone
and umbaku is probably the next leader
in line to
be black panther then we have shuri and
banner working on something that
is really not given any information
about but if i had to
guess i would say it has something to do
with vision
so this next scene is super important we
have black widow in her full gear
and hawkeye's family's home from age of
ultron
in the home everything is thrown all
over the place
and broken and nada is studying some
type of map with multiple
photos and locations on it so i think
the obvious thing that happened here is
hawkeye's family did not survive the
snap he was the only one
and once they were gone he flipped out
and basically destroyed his house and
then
he left on some sort of mission and that
is somehow tracking him with whatever
map that she currently has
the next shot of thanos with a long
sword in an alleyway in new york
means that thanos heads back to earth so
unlike avengers infinity war
where most of the fighting took place on
titan and then in the end there at
wakanda
there will be some fighting in new york
and of course his long sword that they
speak of we have seen in multiple leaked
photos now
then the next shot is a dark-hooded
figure with glowing eyes aiming a bow
and arrow before shooting towards the
camera
this is ronan not hawkeye
ronin in the comics clint barton
experiences
a traumatic event captain america dying
this causes him to hang up the mantle of
hawkeye and take on the persona of ronan
it's been heavily speculated that his
family dying will be the tragic event in
avengers 4 that makes him become
ronin so if this leak is legit that is
in fact true
they show a few scenes of the quantum
realm and scott lang but then they show
thor and valkyrie aboard a cree ship
thor
says if the stories are true you're our
universe's last hope
if such a thing even exists anymore now
clearly
they are talking to captain marvel it
seems like thor and valkyrie sought her
out and apparently they've heard stories
ones that i'm sure we'll see in captain
marvel
telling how strong she is so clearly
they
seek her out based on these stories that
they've heard
i'm not sure how this falls into place
with nick fury's space pager thing
but i'm sure he signals her and she
comes in closer maybe she was off in a
distant galaxy or something
got the message and came close and
that's when thor and valkyrie found her
we then have tony stark decked out in
shield gear walking through the new
shield headquarters which is the
avengers headquarters in upstate new
york
carrying an orange briefcase not sure
what's in the orange briefcase but
with nick fury and maria hill gone it
would make sense that he would take over
shield
we've also seen some leaked photos where
tony is wearing some shield attire so
this matches up perfectly the next scene
that matters is ant-man appearing out of
a flash of light which is most likely
him coming out of the quantum realm
we see this scene from his point of view
from inside of his helmet
land in a desolate place he looks around
all confused
and says what the and then it pans on
vormir and the stars
now the soul stone could have sent him
there but i'm guessing that these are
probably
two different scenes the next shot is of
rocket and nebula modifying some new
weapons just like
rocket likes to do clearly him and
nebula have made
some sort of new weapon that is going to
be pretty effective against thanos or at
least they think
rocket says when can we try this bad boy
out and they both smile at each other
and fist bump
this is most likely added in the trailer
to add a little bit of humor into it
we then get our first glimpse of iron
man and his red and gold nanotech armor
some people are believing this to be the
mark 51 armor
hulk then falls from the sky and lands
right in front of him
thanos is in full armor and smiles hulk
smiles back
this is clearly their rematch and going
by the stinger in the description
hulk has clearly been training for this
which would explain why he smiles and of
course
thanos smiles because he thinks he can
beat the hulk with ease just like last
time
so the next shot is in japan and we have
war machine nat
and steve and their full avengers gear
kind of feels like the secret avengers
again and they're surrounded by
the yakuza they're most likely in japan
looking for
clint or ronan and he comes in and walks
through everybody from behind them and
approaches the avengers
there's an intense exchange of looks
between clint and natasha
so what it sounds like is happening is
that clint went to japan
and went undercover with the yakuza when
he discovers the avengers are there
he goes and he finds them and this
intense look that he gives natalie
is really just a signal that says that
they're about to attack the yakuza
the next part is really interesting
because i thought about this
a lot before because wang isn't actually
talked a lot about when it comes to
avengers 4
theories but it shows him in the sanctum
communicating with dr strange's soul via
a portal
to me this just makes sense they are
learned in the mystic arts
i'm sure they could figure out some way
to talk to souls and in fact i'm sure
that's actually part of dr strange's
plan
we then have a gray-haired tony stark
and ant-man
in a post-apocalyptic new york city the
screen flashes back and forth multiple
times through multiple scenes
again in the trailer they're most likely
going to show a few times that they're
going to time travel which is most
likely what we see here
then we see captain marvel floating in
the air with her fists on fire and her
eyes lit up
captain marvel is said to be one of the
strongest mcu characters so it would
make sense that she has a big important
part in avengers 4.
the next scene is kind of big thanos is
in the soul stone with
young gamora screaming at him clearly
thanos loves gamora and struggles with
the fact that he had to sacrifice her to
get the soul stone
since he is the wielder of the soul
stone perhaps he can visit her or
perhaps he's trying to figure out a way
to get her out of there
then loki and thor are fighting off the
chitari together
this could be in the first avengers
movie in the battle of new york
or it could be present time i think a
lot of people believe that
loki is still alive he's the god of
mischief i don't know many people who
actually think he's dead
and i think it'll be really cool to see
him fight with thor again
tony hands steve a brand new shield in
the wakanda throne room which is
long overdue cap has been without his
original shield since civil war so it's
about time he picks it up again
and hopefully it's got some nanotech
enhancement to it
it then shows tony opening up the orange
briefcase and scott hands him an
illuminated bracelet in which tony asks
how is this even possible this is
probably the first time that tony finds
out about time travel
because the next scene is him and scott
running through the quantum realm and
ending up
back at the battle of new york from
2012. the last scene
is a final shot of the infinity gauntlet
showing an infinity stone
disappearing what i think happens here
is ant-man takes it and then disappears
into the quantum realm
at first thanos is infuriated and he
puts on his armor preparing for battle
but then he smiles i think he smiles
because he kicked their butts the first
time with ease and i think he's actually
ready for a battle the infinity gauntlet
is damaged so it probably won't be
as easy for him but i think that he
likes that i think he's looking forward
to the challenge
so it cuts to the title annihilation i
don't think this is
anything new the title annihilation came
from some pretty reliable sources and
not just one
but multiple reliable sources and then
we have
the stinger which is after the credits
right before the trailer end and we see
professor hulk steve notices that the
hulk has been training
non-stop as of late and asks why and the
hulk responds in banner's normal voice
obviously since he's professor hulk he
says my rematch is coming real soon
i can feel it it's pretty clear that
both banner and the hulk are pretty
ticked off that they lost to thanos so
easily in avengers infinity war
so it's pretty clear that they're ready
to get their revenge so there you have
it the avengers 4
trailer description and breakdown not
sure if this
is true or not but i must say it's
probably exactly what i want from the
movie
it all seems to line up with everything
that we know so far about avengers 4
and everything that we hope will happen
with avengers 4. nothing seemed too off
about it it all made perfect sense it
all flowed well
so this could be legitimate and
apparently the trailer is supposed to
come
in just a few weeks that seems pretty
short but hey you never really know
the russo brothers did say that we'd see
it after captain marvel
but let me know what you all think what
did you think about this description
of the avengers 4 trailer and how
excited are you to see it when it
finally comes out
let me know and don't forget to
subscribe like and comment below with
your thoughts on your favorite superhero
so you can enter the giveaway and stay
up to date with everything relating to
avengers 4.
thank you so much for watching woof
[Music]
you